[Música]
[Aplausos]
hoje quase 50% do mundo reside em áreas
rurais
porém apenas 24% dos médicos decidi
trabalhar nessas áreas rurais
mas como eu descobri isso em 2014 eu fui
pela ciência sem fronteiras para a
irlanda
e lá eu consegui um estágio com o médico
de família e comunidade em uma
comunidade rural numa ilha no
arquipélago
a primeira vez que eu fui pra lá eu
embarquei num ônibus do centro
movimentado da cidade que estava morando
e fui em direção à zona rural
a cada quilômetro era mais e mais verde
e menos e menos carros
quando cheguei na parada de ônibus e de
si
eu fiquei muito preocupado eu peguei meu
celular não tinha sinal não tinha
internet
aí eu sentei e fiquei esperando médico
em buscam até ele chegar
eu já tinha feito mil planos para voltar
para a cidade mas ainda bem
eu esperei ele chegar e embarquei no
carro e quando embarquei eu estava
embarcando numa das melhores vivências
da minha vida
logo comecei a conversar com ele que
estava há 30 anos trabalhando na mesma
comunidade
eu achava incrível o quanto ele conhecia
os pacientes já tinha cuidado de
gerações cinco gerações de uma família
tinha feito o pré natal da mãe da avó
acompanhava o neto
e aí eu ia perguntando no começo porque
não acreditava que ele conhecia todo
mundo quem mora ali
quem mora lá quem mora naquela casa e
ele é incrivelmente conhecia todas as
casas do arquipélago e uma coisa muito
marcante na saúde rural é a necessidade
da criatividade
às vezes a gente precisava chamar a
ambulância nos casos de emergência
e aí ele ele tinha sacos coloridos que a
gente ia pendurando nas cercas
o sax e aí a gente sabia o caminho para
indicar o motorista quando você tiver
tal sacos e dobra lá continental só que
o dólar
precisa dessa criatividade para lidar
quando você tem mais adversidades a
distância e o tempo todo o tratamento
adequado na zona rural é muito maior em
relação à zona urbana o cuidado chegar a
demora mais ea gente precisa estar
preparado como profissionais de saúde
vai lidar com essas situações e muitas
vezes mesmo tendo um sistema de
referência adequado
os profissionais os pacientes vão optar
por não ficar né ou por ficar sendo
cuidados por não ir para o hospital e
ficar sendo cuidado na sua zona rural
então a gente precisa estar mais
preparado para lidar com essas situações
e claro que depois que eu descobri e
conhecia as mãos dos trabalhadores
rurais da irlanda eu jamais ia conseguir
deixar de lado a medicina de família e
comunidade rural ea saúde rural rural é
tão diferente do urbano que quando você
abre a porta para chamar um paciente
eu não sei o que vai entrar pode ser uma
picada por cobra pode ser um acidente
com a raia pode ser uma intoxicação por
agrotóxico pode ser uma depressão
diabetes hipertensão pode ser uma
história fantástica e eu gostaria de
dividir duas histórias essas já dentro
do brasil que vive em uma dessas portas
que a oab estava conversando com o
médico de família e comunidade que
trabalha no interior do brasil
eu pergunto a gente estava comentando
ele falando mas ganharam quando eu era
jovem eu trabalhava na roça eu plantava
fumo e durante a época de passar veneno
fumo e passava o dia inteiro passando
veneno a noite inteira me tanto o dia
inteiro passando veneno a noite inteira
vomitando
infelizmente essa não é uma realidade
que só ele vive hoje 70 mil pessoas
morrem ao ano pelo uso de agrotóxicos e
pelo menos 7 milhões têm toxic ações
agudas ou crônicas e sofrem doenças por
estas intoxicações ações e hoje esse
médico ainda bem faltou né a trabalhar
na terra com saúde rural e se antes ele
plantava fun
hoje ele ajuda as pessoas a pararem de
fumar mas não para aí
outro dia estava atendendo um paciente
estruturando a mão dele ele tinha se
cortado com o facão na quarta do paço e
eu tinha estava segurando estava falando
que ele tinha que usar luva que ele
tinha que usar equipamentos de proteção
individual e conversando aí no final meu
preceptor nem o professor falou assim
mas mera seja curta ou pasta
e você já cortou pasta usando luva no
caso não também aí ele disse pois é eu
tentei implantar a pasta e cortar e foi
impossível utilizando a luva nas duas
mãos
hoje eu tento pelo menos negociar com o
paciente para usar na luva que mais
sofre cortes e eu acho que essa empatia
de se colocar no lugar do próximo dessas
pessoas que vivem uma realidade muito
diferente em geral da nossa vida urbana
é fundamental
bom aí voltando pra mim é história da
irlanda
cheguei no brasil muito bem obrigado
fui começar a conversar com os meus
colegas sobre saúde rural
fomos aos professores as pessoas me
olhavam assim saúde rural sem existe
algumas pessoas têm tal aquela abordagem
mais compreensível que vocês sabem batia
nas minhas costas
que legal essa experiência na irlanda
mas aqui não tem isso aqui você tem que
ter foco no caso estava perdendo meu
foco é bom
enquanto eu não encontrava os médicos os
profissionais que trabalham com saúde
rural no brasil porque logo que eu
cheguei me senti um pouco órfão que não
estava encontrando os meus pares
eu comecei a conversar com profissionais
do mundo inteiro e aí em 2015 ver idéia
de criar um projeto chamado hope e médio
em café
apelidado de café rural em uma
plataforma mundial na qual gente conecta
profissionais do mundo inteiro através
do youtube facebook e twitter
a gente faz uma reunião ao vivo no
youtube se conecta no facebook e um
filho no twitter vocês terem uma ideia
hoje a gente está na 26ª edição
então com dois anos de projeto mais de
100 pessoas participaram mais de 40
países e esse projeto que criava foi
praticamente criada que inicialmente no
brasil vai estar na próxima reunião na
próxima conferência da organização
mundial de saúde sobre força de trabalho
em saúde ea gente vai estar lá fazendo
uma edição de saúde rural em algumas
semanas para discutir os profissionais
de saúde na zona rural
aí eu cheguei no brasil e finalmente
encontrei um grupo de trabalho da
sociedade brasileira de medicina de
família e comunidade e queria colocar os
meus pés na terra fazendo um chilam
pelos interiores ruralidades brasileiras
era minha vez de colocar os pés era uma
viagem pelos meus interiores e pelos
interiores do brasil
comecei pelo lugar da minha formação em
rio grande indo visitar a comunidade da
quentinha e aí ele lá eu pegava também
saía do cd no centro da cidade está
morando uma marmita porque não tinha
almoço
ia lá pra comer marmita na hora do
almoço e ficar né a cuidar dos pacientes
e almoçará inclusive na casa de alguns
pacientes aprendendo sobre as plantas
medicinais conhecendo aquela comunidade
e aí eu peguei a minha mochila e fui pra
caruaru pernambuco na seca
eu nunca vou esquecer de uma história
que eu vivi lá eu estava com o paciente
ea gente está fazendo uma lista uma
lista das coisas que mais estavam
atrapalhando dele e tinha hipertensão
diabetes conflitos familiares de
desemprego e eu perguntei pra ele
nessa lista aqui que mais te incomoda
ele olhou bem fundo nos meus olhos e
disse à seca
eu não podia fazer chover não adianta
hoje a gente ter os melhores
profissionais
os melhores consultores os melhores
equipamentos
se o cuidado ainda não chega nas áreas
rurais a oms estima a organização
internacional do trabalho estima que o
déficit de saúde global é 2,5 vezes
maior nas áreas rurais em relação às
áreas urbanas pelo menos 10 milhões
existe uma escassez de 10
milhões de profissionais saúde hoje nas
áreas que mais precisam ea previsão é
que em 2030 a gente tem uma estimativa
de de ter que precisar de 40 milhões de
profissionais de saúde
porém eles vão se concentrar onde nas
áreas mais desenvolvidas nos países
desenvolvidos e os países de média baixa
e baixa renda ainda prevêem uma escassez
de 18 milhões de profissionais de saúde
pois então vamos olhar alguns mapas
juntos as áreas em verde escuro são as
áreas que correspondem às áreas mais
rurais do mundo
coincidentemente quais vocês acham que
são os países de média baixa e baixa
renda
esses são os países 70% do mundo que
vive na pobreza extrema
vive em áreas rurais então por que a
gente não forma profissionais para
trabalhar nas áreas rurais se devem
estar se perguntando o bom parar pra
pensar
olhando assim talvez esse não é um
problema do brasil porque o brasil é bem
clarinho andré verde escuro a gente não
tem uma população rural muito grande
de acordo com o censo oficial 15% do
brasil reside em áreas rurais o que
equivale mais ou menos a 30 milhões de
pessoas
pois então a definição de rural no
brasil começou na no durante o estado
novo onde rural foi considerado área
externa o perímetro urbano
então tudo o que fosse e todas as
cidades teriam seriam categorizados o
seu centro como cidades o como urbano e
tudo que fosse fora disso seria rural
mas então isso acaba fazendo uma
superestimação onde o número de pai de
pequenos municípios de baixa demografia
acabam sendo muito superestimados por
serem considerados todos como urbanos
beleza
agora você olha essa imagem aqui vocês
acham que ele está falando de uma zona
urbana ou rural
com certeza a gente está falando de uma
zona urbana
pelas definições das leis brasileiras
neste local tem meio fio e
redes de iluminação elétrica além disso
ele está a menos de três quilômetros de
uma unidade de saúde e essa é as portas
e mandar de saúde
nós vamos colocar um pouco de história
nesses dados
afinal história são dados com alma certo
dia chegou um paciente muito mal e ele
precisou a médica pessoa fazer as más a
massagem cardíaca iniciar as manobras de
ressuscitação e aí ela pediu pro na
equipe
por favor chame a ambulância aí a equipe
ou ela mas doutora não tem telefone
urbana esse que não tem nem telefone né
graças a deus os profissionais
brasileiros têm lidado com muita muita
muita criatividade
são unidades de saúde fluviais são
formas de chegar até as pessoas composto
de saúde móveis e de alcançar essas
comunidades
eu nunca vou esquecer né do agente
comunitário de saúde que é uma forma de
ampliar o acesso da saúde rural
mostrando as cicatrizes nas pernas das
mordidas de cachorro
são agentes comunitárias que pulam
portões para fazer com que cheguem até a
casa das pessoas andam quilômetros de
bicicleta de moto de cavalo gastou a
sola dos sapatos a pé
fica minha homenagem elas aqui mas eu
queria dividir ainda uma história com
vocês eu fui também para minas gerais no
interior de minas gerais
e lá eu como eu estava acompanhando uma
senhora jovem uma mulher jovem no final
da vida com cuidados paliativos ea já
estava resoluta com a morte
eu perguntei dela de tudo o que ela
fazia antes da doença que ela gostava
que ela me falou pudim de leite
rapidamente
anotei receita conseguia organizado está
ficando uma casa com se organizava uma
vizinha fazer o tal do pudim de leite
que eu ia levar pra ela veio por gente
leite alguns dias depois cheguei pra ela
um pudim de leite
mostrei na beira da cama ela falou é um
pudim e perguntei
é um pedaço ela olhou pra mim e disse
não eu fiquei um pouco desconcertado com
aquele não né
fiz o que pude e tal mas ela falou pra
mim como você eo médico lá na cozinha
obedecemos que foi lá
comemos um pedaço de pudim e fomos ver
os outros pacientes do dia quando a
gente chegou deu mais ou menos umas duas
horas depois ela ligaram pra avisar que
ela tinha falecido
a gente chegou na casa de novo pra fazer
o atestado de óbito preparar o corpo
chegamos entramos na cozinha tava pudim
em cima da mesa da cozinha e os parentes
estavam comendo pudim
eu fui até o quarto para ajudar a
preparar o corpo tirar o acesso enfim
e aí eu estava fechando a boca dela e eu
percebi que ela estava sorrindo porque é
importante contar essa história pra
vocês porque provavelmente um médico que
trabalha na zona rural vai ser o único
profissional ea equipe inteira vai ser
não ser os únicos profissionais num raio
de quilômetros procurar aquela
comunidade e precisam estar preparados
para lidar com esse tipo de situação
em 2016 a gente criou a rua alcides ou
sementes rurais com essa ideia do rural
aflorando dentro de mim e conversando
com várias pessoas
a gente queria com mundialmente criar um
grupo que fosse integrar jovens médicos
jovens profissionais de saúde com
profissionais experientes com acadêmicos
e que fosse ser um lugar democrático é
que todos pudessem se ouve falar então a
gente criou esse grupo da rua alcides
a gente identificou que principalmente
nos países em desenvolvimento existe uma
falta de mentoria né muitas vezes o
profissional e e ficava isolado em
determinados locais não tinha um
professor não tinha um mentor para
ajudar a orientar aquelas pessoas então
a gente criou um projeto chamado monitor
mente que mentoria mundial e esse é o
primeiro mapa de mentores que a gente
tem foi lançado esse ano esse projeto
e esses são esse é o mapa de mentoria
mundial então por exemplo um médico
recém formado na nigéria pode ser
acompanhado por um mentor a distância da
austrália
o médico recém-formado dos estados
unidos pode ser acompanhado por um motor
experiente com saúde rural do uruguai ou
um médico do nepal com o médico da índia
néon um profissional de saúde de que da
ruanda com um profissional de saúde da
austrália então a gente está diminuindo
as distâncias ea idéia não é fazer o
cuidado pelas pessoas mas responderá às
próprias pessoas a realizarem o seu
cuidado
por fim eu queria pedir para vocês
quantos de vocês já compraram uma batata
qual será
eu quero que vocês pensem comigo nessa
batata qual será que foi o caminho que
ela fez para chegar até aqui
qual foi a terra que ela foi plantada
será que essa batata vai da irlanda ou
do brasil tem mais
será que o agricultor que planta essa
batata que colheu essa batata tem dor
nas costas no final do dia por colher
essa batata será que a pessoa que ponto
essa batata teve uma intoxicação por
agrotóxico
por fim será que essa pessoa tenha
acesso a um serviço de saúde como é o
seu direito
eu vou dizer pra vocês que a saúde rural
não é uma simples comparação com urbano
e não é apenas sobre batatas mas que me
manterei inquieta até que não consiga
saúde para todos em todo mundo inclusive
nas áreas rurais
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]